I've heard about this and I heard it
sold out and I want to know who you
killed to get this on his sleep on Cyber
Monday
Kylie Jenner came out with a line of
lipsticks that sold out in 30 seconds
and got resold on eBay for up to $10,000
we decided to try them out to see if
they live up to the hype its ladylike
and we're testing Kylie Jenner's lip kit
maybe trying candy kay I'm surprised
that candy isn't spelled with a k line
lips with liner go in with liquid
lipstick
remember that Kylie said it Kylie I need
more tips and just line lips also how do
you sharpen these things you guys see
this it's plastic so you can't sharpen
it and there's also no turn thing now
we've got this matte liquid lipstick you
know what matte means gonna draw the
[ __ ] out of my lips look smells like a
lip smacker I wouldn't say it's too late
but it's not my style I look like a
Bratz doll I mean it's like a nice like
demure color this one am i doing it
wrong I feel like I did it wrong okay
it's drying okay it's starting to look a
little better so it's getting darker wow
this stuff is like dry it's like
puckering my lips almost cool that looks
good that matters it's not a very like
lifelike color it is a little like wax
figure it makes me look like an 18 year
old billionaire so all I care about
yeah I'm feeling like this is definitely
like the color of my skin see no one's
done is it look good I don't know it
looks good anymore they all smell so
good goes on great smells great find a
nice nude from a chocolate skin as it
sets in the color gets better it's a
weird sensation like a magic trick on my
face but I like it
I feel pretty cool in this I'm not gonna
lie like I guess there is a positive to
her
black creating this blue lip for black
ladies like myself true brown k they
have candy Dolce and then just brown I'm
holding my breath while I do it I like
hint I can't do it there's no room for
error with this color mary j blige in
the nineties true brown king oh my god
oh it's almost black which I'm really
into I like being the queen of darkness
it's not just possible I like it oh I
feel like an adult it looks like I just
got into a chocolate cake honestly you
can go to the laundry pod I want to kiss
myself I feel like I could date Tyga
kind of lip it looks great what I'm sad
and pouty but when I smile you can see
the lines it's not for smiling I don't
think but as Kim says smile and gives
you wrinkles so don't even smile why are
you been doing that I'm eating a burrito
right now and I really hope that the
Kylie lipstick stands up to the
challenge
[Music]
an apple a bean but it
and popcorn
at water my lips are still on pretty
tough I've been sippin on this all
afternoon and there is no residue I'm
jelly good candy girl Annie said it
looks good from far away and then up
close it looks like the Sahara Desert
yeah you can see the crafts
okay I need car mix how was that I
actually got a lot of compliments it
looks good oh thank you
I think the colors are cool the three
different colors sort of work with a
bunch of different skin tone just which
is really cool
they are wrinkly though I'm gonna give
kind like this one yeah yeah gotta give
it to her Kylie one resentment zero I
would say if you can get online and you
can actually get the lip kits as soon as
they drop sure pay 30 bucks for it but I
wouldn't go on eBay it's been did on lip
kits for thousands of dollars no I wish
that there was more pencil in the lip
liner but that I've been that that is
about it doesn't come with a sharpener
no I don't know we don't know how to
sharpen it